can you tell when this coin was made
1975 no this says
1967 this is an Egyptian coin that uses
Arabic numerals not the Western ones the
Eastern ones the Eastern 6 looks like
the Western 7 and the Eastern 7 looks
like the Roman numeral 5 oh and the
Eastern five looks like the Western zero
this Egyptian coin isn't worth nothing
it's worth five kersch but enough about
East and West let's talk about North and
South because we made a watch that goes
the other way because clockwise is for
clock fools oh but Michael I want a
watch that goes in the same direction as
a Sund dial wake up look down don't let
the north tell you which way things go
I'm sending one of these to every box
subscriber this month it will come on a
big orange hand because even though I'm
wacky I'm not
silly